learn to use r to create an interactive
data driven application using the r
shiny package dr chanin natasanamat also
known as the data professor teaches this
course besides teaching on his youtube
channel he is also a university
professor you probably know that the r
programming language can help you to
perform statistical analysis but did you
know that you could use r to build an
interactive data-driven web application
in this course on free codecam you will
be learning about how you could use the
r shiny package to build an interactive
and data driven web application that
will range from a simple
application that allows you to print
user inputs web applications that will
allow you to display data visualization
as well as web application that will
allow you to make predictions from
machine learning models
finally you'll be learning how to deploy
the web applications that you have
created to the cloud by means of the
heroku platform all codes that are used
in this tutorial will be provided in the
video description and without further
ado let's dive in
before we begin let's cover the basics
of what is a shiny package so shiny is
an r package that allows you to build an
interactive web application there are
several extension packages that will
allow you to extend the function of
shiny including shiny themes shiny
dashboard shiny js and several others
and once you develop your web app in
shiny then you want to deploy it so you
have two options you want to deploy it
on your own server for example using a
service like digitalocean or to a shiny
apps dot io there are lots of example
codes that can get you started and this
is available in the shiny gallery so the
links are in the slides okay so what we
will learn today first of all we will
learn about the structure of a shiny web
application and then we're going to have
a look at some of the examples of the
shiny web application and finally we
will show you step by step how you can
build your interactive web application
so let's have a look at the structure of
a shiny web application so essentially a
shiny web app comprises of three
components so the first component is the
user interface which is housed within a
file called ui dot r and the second is
the server function which will perform
the processing of the data which is
housed in the file called server.r and
then the shiny app function will fuse
the ui and server components together so
the ui is the front end that accepts the
user input values the server is the back
end that processes these input values to
finally produce output results that are
displayed on the website okay so you see
that input data will flow into the user
interface which is the website that you
see and then you will enter data into
the text box and then the data will be
submitted to the server the server
processes the information and then it
will produce the result and the result
is displayed on the website okay and
then the user will see the results okay
so let's have a look at some of the
shiny web applications so let's go to
this link
okay so this is the gallery available
from shinee and you can see that there
are a lot of examples
so there are the integration of maps
right inside shiny application and also
interactive scatter plots you can also
embed google charts as well you could
perform k-means clustering you could
create some bar charts using available
data set from the data set package and
then you could also create a word cloud
okay and there are several others and
then there are widgets like
buttons tables slider input slider okay
downloading files uploading files
subsetting data set and all that okay so
there are several examples on how you
can develop custom shiny web apps so why
don't we click on one the first one okay
so this map is interactive if we click
on it we can zoom in
right so you click on the
color and then it will update the map
based on your input
or also data explorer so it's an
interactive table you can also sort the
data as well okay or how about a word
cloud generator
and then you can play around with the
input parameters the minimum frequency
of each word for example if it's 25 it
means that the current word like love
has to be present at least 25 times or
26 times in order for it to be counted
here how many words are we limiting to
be displayed here okay and these accept
input from the books of our choice a
midsummer's night dream the merchant of
venice or romeo and juliet
we have to click on the change button
okay
okay mean clustering
using the iris data set
right okay
okay and then the next one is to have a
look at some of the web applications
coming out of my own research lab so
let's have a look let's go to code stop
bio slash osfp so as i'm a
bioinformatics researcher and data
scientist so what we do in our lab is we
try to apply machine learning in order
to make sense of biological data and
chemical data as well and so the
objective of this web server is to take
as input the protein sequence and then
we will predict whether the protein
sequence is an oligomer or a monomer
okay so let's click on the insert
example data and then the input will be
a fast a format of the protein sequence
so the first line which contains the
greater than symbol followed by the name
of the protein is given here so we see
that the first protein is a monomer and
the second protein is a tetramer and
let's click on the submit button to make
the prediction
okay so we see that the prediction is
correct on both occasions because the
first one is a monomer and it predicts
it to be a monomer and the second one is
a tetramer and it predicts it to be an
oligomer okay so this is the interface
of the prediction web server and if you
click on the other buttons it will look
like any other ordinary website okay so
these are description on how to use the
web server and they are written in
markdown okay so this shiny app can also
embed markdown inside as well okay so we
also provide the data set for download
as well and we host it on the github and
if you're interested in reading this
paper you can click on the link okay so
this is the paper that we published back
in 2016
in the journal of chem informatics
okay so let's go back to slide
and let's get started with creating our
own web app using shiny so what you want
to do now is fire up your rstudio or
rstudio.cloud okay and so the code that
will be used today is available on the
data professor github so if you go to
github.com
data professor okay and then you click
on code
and then find shiny slash 0 1 first app
and then you want to click on app.r
and then you want to right click on the
raw button right here
and then you want to click on the save
link as
and then select a suitable position
where you want to save the file
and because i already have it i will
just click on cancel but if you don't
have it yet click on the save button
okay so let's open up the app.r file
right inside the rstudio okay so before
we begin a credit to winston chang for
developing this template by which we
greatly modified and simplified to make
this app.r file okay so if you wanna
check out the full version go ahead here
links are provided here okay so in this
simplification we're going to
start with the baby steps so this web
app is an interactive web application
whereby it will accept input values in
the form of text primarily the given
name and surname so let's have a look
okay so the app will accept input which
is the given name and the surname okay
so let's go ahead and type the given
name john and insert nameless still
okay and so the name john doe will
appear in the output here and the name
of the app is my first app you can also
modify this to your own liking okay and
in this example we have three navigation
bar and so we intentionally left it
blank here according to the original
template by winston chang okay so the
code that we have is located on the
navbar.1 so a point in node is that you
can also create several web apps inside
different navigation bar let's say that
you want to modify the name like let's
say given name is jennifer so then you
see that the name is automatically
updated so notice that there is no
submit button and whenever you type an
updated name
it will
automatically update the results so in r
they implement reactive
let's have a look
shiny reactive reactive expressions
reactivity and overview okay so it's
based on the principles of reactive
programming which is used by the shiny
package okay so we're not going to go
into detail but if you're interested i
can also provide the links in the file
as well
concepts about reactive programming used
by
shiny
okay so i'm going to provide the link
for you
here
okay so a moment ago we have taken a
look at how the web application will
look like which is the end outcome of
this code and so let's look under the
hood what does the code looks like okay
so in the slides i've shown to you that
it comprises of three components so
let's have a look so the first component
is the ui it's right here
so it's on line 19 until lines 43 okay
lines 19 until lines 43 this is the ui
or the user interface and then on lines
47 until 52 is the server component so
you're going to notice that we're not
doing anything much here we're just
displaying the results and so the code
is very concise and the third component
is the shiny app function so this thing
will piece together the ui and the
server so it's essentially just saying
that okay this part here is the ui this
part here is the server and fuse them
both to create a shiny app object okay
so that's all there is to it at the
conceptual level so let's have a look at
the
components inside the ui object okay so
here is using inside the fluid page tag
it's using the theme argument and it's
telling that we want to use the cerulean
theme okay and the cerulean theme is the
blue theme that you've seen a moment ago
let's say that i want to change it to
united and i can click on the reload oh
i need to save it first and then i'll
click on the reload and then it changes
to the united
okay and i want to change to let's say
yeti save it
and then it becomes the yeti theme
so maybe you're wondering what's the
available options for you
so if you search for shiny themes in
google
okay the first results and just click on
it
so here this is how a cerulean looks
like if you like that and you could type
in cerulean there's cosmo
cyborg darkly
paper lumen journal flatly readable
sandstone
simplex
slate
space lab
superhero united
and yeti let's try superhero
okay so it's
john doe okay
there you go
i just default back to cerulean
so let's envisage the code as modular
components so you're gonna see that
inside the ui you're going to have a
fluid page okay and within this fluid
page you're gonna define the theme and
inside the fluid page aside from the
theme you're gonna have a navigation bar
page right so the navigation bar page is
right here it's this bar and so the name
of the app is my first app so this is
the name of the navigation bar page
inside the nav bar page there is the tab
panel okay the tab panel comprises of
navbar one navbar two navbar three again
inside navbar one you have the sidebar
panel right here to the left right you
have here sidebar panel and your sidebar
panel contains tag h3 h3 is the heading
third level heading input and then text
input is the given name and the text
input is the type of input so if you
change this to something else it will
look differently here and there are a
lot of widgets okay so you can find what
you want you can shop for what widget
you like and then just replace it right
here in the code okay so the given name
is right here displayed here and then
this thing here is the default value so
let's say that i could type in john doe
and let's save it and reload the app so
you see that john doe will automatically
by default appear in the text box okay
but i can also leave it blank as well
right so this is the contents of the
sidebar panel so the sidebar panel will
accept the input right and then the main
panel is right here where we see header
one output one john doe which is the
result so in main panel one right header
one is inside the h1 so h1 is the tag
which is the biggest tag available and
h4 is a smaller tag right so we have in
order of from big to small we have h1
and then h2 h3h4 right so for the input
here we use h3 if we change it to h1 it
will be bigger
it'll be the same size as the header one
here but it's too big so i'm going to
change it to
just h3
we can even make this h3 as well
right so it got a little bit bigger for
the output one here
right so you can play around with
changing the options here okay and so
verbatim text output is simply a text
box that will return the output value so
it's just a simple text box and then the
navbar 2 navbar 3 as we have previously
mentioned it is intentionally left blank
okay so there's that's all there is to
the ui but the confusing part is how
does ui and server interact how do they
send information back and forth right
how does ui send the input value to the
server and how does the server accept
the input value okay let's have a look
right here so notice that the text box
has this thing called text one txt one
right in the given name okay and the
surname is txt2 okay notice that make a
note of that how about i put it in the
comments
txt1
and
txt2 okay and make a note of this too
txt out
txt out okay so these two
will be sent
to
to the server
txt2 will also be sent
txt out is generated from the server
[Music]
okay so let's go back to the slides okay
why don't i create a new slide so let's
duplicate this slide so let's call this
the first web app and we're going to
modify this to reflect the contents of
this web app okay so the input data is
txt1
and txt2 right and the output is txt out
right so it will send txt 1 and 62 to
the server and
so actually the server sends right txt
out
and then txt out will be displayed
displays txt out
so here
txt1 and txt2 will be sent to the server
txt1 and txt2 here as input dollar sign
txt one and input dollar sign txt2 okay
and so the question is how does it send
it as the txt out it's right here output
dollar sign txt out and it's going to
use this function called render text
okay so there's several render function
like render table render text right that
you can modify so you can also find out
from the shiny documentation okay so
this output txt out what it essentially
does is it will use the paste function
to combine txt1 and txt2 and separate it
by a empty space and then it will
produce the result as the concatenated
text of txt 1 and 62 inside the txt out
variable and then this variable will be
called from within the verbatim text
output and then it will display the text
inside the text box that's all there is
to this shiny web application it will
seem a bit confusing but if you get the
concepts straight it will be very simple
and you could create any web application
to your own imagination okay you can
make this web application data driven
you could ask input you could upload a
file of the input data and then the
input data will be sent to the server
right and then in the server you could
create a machine learning model and then
once the machine learning model is built
it would then relay the results back
into the ui and then the ui will display
the predicted results okay so this will
be very powerful as a model deployment
approach for your machine learning model
okay and there's several tips and tricks
which we use in our research lab and we
can share this in a future video and so
if you're finding value out of this
video please smash the like button okay
so let me recap this process in summary
this app.r file will contain three
components the ui component which is the
user interface it will accept input
which is the txt1 and txt2 which
corresponds to the given name and the
surname and when you input the given
name and surname it will be sent to the
server and then the paste function will
combine txt1 and txt2 and put it inside
a txt out variable and then this txt out
variable is embedded inside the verbatim
text output which is a text box on the
ui and as a result you will see the
input values that you typed in displayed
in the text box okay so this is a first
web app which is essentially starting
from the basics so nothing fancy here
just a simple web app where you could
type in the name the first name last
name and then it will display the result
okay so in future videos of this series
called the web app in r we're going to
have several other videos and if you
have ideas on what application you would
like us to develop let us know so please
comment down below and i'll see you in
the next one
okay so this video represents the second
episode of the web apps in r series in
the first video we covered how you can
develop your very first shiny web app
and the web app allows you to enter the
first name and last name and the web app
will display the output for example if
you enter the first name as john and the
last name as do then the output panel
will then output john doe so in this
video we're going to show you how you
can develop your second web app in r and
so the web app today is really quite
simple the web app will display a
histogram of the air quality data set
particularly the ozone levels and the
user will be able to adjust the bin size
and then the histogram will adjust
accordingly
okay so let's get started so what you
want to do now is go to the data
professor github so click on the code
folder
and then click on the shiny folder
and then click on the 002 histogram and
then what you want to do now is click on
the app.r
and then right click on the raw link and
then save link as
and then save it to a desired
destination so since i have already
downloaded the file so let's open up the
app.r file so why don't we go ahead and
run the application
so as you can see the web app has the
title as the ozone level and the side
panel shown on the left has the number
of bins as a slider input value so you
can adjust this by sliding to the left
or right and then the resulting
histogram will be updated automatically
in real time
so let's say that we adjusted to seven
bins and you will see that in the
histogram there will be a total of 7
bars if you adjust it to
12 then the number of bins or the number
of bars will then be adjusted to 12. so
what is a bin bin in a histogram is
essentially the number of bars and each
bar represents a range in the value for
example from the range of zero to
five or zero to ten and so if you adjust
it to one bar then you will see only one
bar here and if you adjusted two bins
you would see two bars right and etc
and for a maximum of 50 bars okay so
let's go back to the code so in this
app.r file you will see that on line
number nine it essentially loads the
shiny library and line number 10 will
load the air quality data set into the
memory and i have already pinned the ui
in red here
and the server in red
and the shiny app function in red so as
in the previous
video i have already mentioned that the
shiny app has essentially three major
components consisting of the ui
component which is the user interface
and the server component will accept the
input value from the ui and it will do
some processing as shown here
and finally it will generate the output
and the output will then be sent back to
the ui for display in the main panel
okay so let's recap that again so this
ui is the user interface and it will
allow you to specify the name of the
title panel here which is specified as
ozone level so let's have a look
so ozone level is specified by the title
panel so you can modify this name if you
like
okay so let's say you want to call it
just ozone
and then you have to save it and then
reload the app okay and then the app
will then be called ozone okay okay so
this is the title panel here and the
next block of code here will be the
sidebar layout and the sidebar layout
will allow you to specify the sidebar
panel and inside the sidebar panel will
then be a slider input and the slider
input is essentially the number of bins
right number of bins in the
ui and it will have an input id of bins
which the server component will
recognize okay i'm going to show you in
just a moment and so the minimum value
here is 1 and the maximum value of the
bin is 50 and the default value is 30.
so you see here that the minimum is one
the maximum is 50 and the default value
is 30. so you can adjust the maximum
let's say 40 and the default you can
adjust it to 20 and then we will save it
and reload the app okay and then you're
going to see that the web app
automatically updates to 1 and 40 and
with a default of 20. okay and you when
you slide it it'll update as before
so here you can see that the step size
is one because when you slide the button
it will incrementally increase by one
let's say that you want to modify the
step size to another number can you do
that
yes you can
so you want to specify step to be equal
to
let's say
two
and the minimum you want to adjust it to
zero save it and reload the app and here
now the step size becomes two okay so 18
and then you move it it becomes 20. you
move it it becomes 22 okay so you notice
that i've also modified the minimum to
be zero because if it's one then the
step size will be one three five seven
nine but if you make it into an even
number then the step size will be also
even number okay so let's have a look if
the step size is one
it will be one three five
right it will be one three five so i
cannot select twenty okay so it has to
be only odd numbers
so if you want it to be even number then
you want to put the minimum to become
zero
okay
here now
you can even make the step size to be
five
right
zero five 10
25 30 right
okay so notice that the slider input has
an input id of bins and let's go into
the server component
and let's find bins where it spins spins
is right here and bins is right here
okay so the server component will have
two bins the input bins and it will be
the value of the argument breaks okay so
it will allow you to specify the number
of bins in the histogram and x will be
the air quality data set and then we use
the dollar sign to specify the column
called ozone because in air quality data
set let me stop the shiny app first
let's have a look air quality
dollar sign
and then notice that you have ozone you
have solar you have wind you have
temperature month
day
okay so we specify ozone
and we'll also notice that ozone has
some missing data
right it has some missing data here
shown as n a so what we're going to do
with the missing data is to omit it from
the data set using the na.omit function
and then save it back into the x
variable okay and then the bins variable
will then determine what is the minimum
value of the bin and what is the maximum
value of the bin
okay so moving on to the next function
is the histogram function where x is the
input data which is the air quality
ozone column and the breaks will be
equal to the number of bins that we
specify here okay and so the color will
be this color which is blueish color and
the border will be black so this is the
blue color mentioned in here and the
border is black so we see a black line
and the x label is also level so the x
label is right here and then the main is
histogram of ozone level so main is
right here right so you can adjust label
or also the main text as well so in this
output dollar sign this plot we will use
the render plot and then this will
generate an output called output dist
plot
and then we're going to notice if we
scroll up to the main panel of the ui
component
the plot output function will have an
output id equals to this plot okay so
the name this plot here and this point
here are the same object so the server
will generate this output object called
this plot and sends it to the ui
component for display on the main panel
so the main panel is located right here
okay so finally the shiny app function
will fuse together the ui component and
the server component so you're going to
see that the code communicates between
the ui and the server right so the ui
will accept the input which is the
number of bins and it will send the
number of bins to the server component
and the server component will generate
the histogram plot
and the histogram plot will be contained
within this output this plot and it will
be sent to the plot output function in
the main panel of the ui and so you will
see the resulting histogram being
generated and if you adjust the value of
the input bin number then the plot will
also update automatically using the
reactive function of shiny okay so you
can customize the color if you like
let's make it
zero zero two three six six
okay so it's dark blue
or what if we just call it
blue
or how about let's use red
okay so the plot will become red
if we use green
okay so the histogram will also be green
so
so here you can customize the color to
your own liking and experiment and
don't forget to upload this to your
github so that you can start building
your portfolio for data science projects
and then you're going to have several
repository in your github in no time
congratulations you have built your
second shiny web application in r
okay so this is the third episode of the
web apps in r series so today we're
going to build a play golf web
application so probably you're wondering
what is the play golf application so the
play golf web application that we're
going to build today is going to be
based on the weather data set provided
by the weka data mining software so
let's have a look here so the data set
is a relatively small data set where it
has a total of five variables so four
variables are the outlook temperature
humidity and the wind and the class
label would be to play or not play golf
which is a function of the weather and
the condition right like whether it is
sunny whether the temperature is high
whether the humidity is high or low or
medium and whether there is wind or not
true or false and then the final
decision is to either play or not play
golf okay so before we dive into the
code let's have a look at how does the
web application looks like okay so the
web app looks like this it's a very
simple application so the name of the
web app is play golf and so here there
is the input parameters comprising of
the four variables that i have mentioned
the first one is the outlook and so the
user can select one of three outlook
whether it is sunny whether there is
overcast of cloud and also whether there
is rain or not and the second variable
is the temperature and so this is a
slider input so the user can
slide the input value and then the
humidity is also a slider input and then
windy is either a yes or a no which is a
drop down menu and then when you're
ready to make a prediction you just
click on the submit button
okay and here you see a prediction is
being made and the prediction says yes
and then we also see the underlying
probability in that the no has a 27
probability and the yes has a 73
probability and so you could play around
with this right if for example if it is
sunny and the humidity is very high and
the temperature is very high and there
is wind should you play golf no right i
mean really if if the temperature is
high it's very humid and it's very windy
and it's sunny right probably not right
okay what if it's what if the humidity
is low temperature is quite cool and
it's sunny and it's not so windy would
you play golf right yes right so there's
a 87 probability for yes and a 13
probability for no okay so this is the
web app we're going to build today so
let's go ahead and stop the
web app for a moment
okay so what you want to do now is go to
the
data professor github and then you want
to click on the code directory
and followed by clicking on the shiny
directory
and finally clicking on the zero zero
three play golf directory
and then click on the app.r file
okay so what you want to do is
right click on the raw link and then
save to file so i'm going to save it
into the weather folder save it okay
it's right here click on it make sure
that the app works
okay it works prediction has been made
okay cool so let's just clear up this by
pressing on the control and l button
okay so let's have a look under the hood
what does the app.r file looks like so
the first couple of lines will just
import the libraries used by this app.r
file so this comprises of the shiny
package shiny themes package the data
dot table library the r curl library and
the random forest library okay so next
line of code would be to create a data
object called weather by reading the csv
which is downloaded from the data
professor github in the data folder and
the file is called
weather.weca dot csv
okay let's have a look at the data set
what does it look like i'll click on the
line weather and then i hit on the
control and enter button and then let's
type in weather okay so this is what we
see
let's go with head and then weather
okay and so we see that there are five
columns outlook temperature humidity
windy and play
right and let's have a look at the data
type
of the data set
we see that the outlook has three factor
levels play has two factor levels so
these are categorical label no yes and
the outlook is overcast rainy and sunny
windy is a true and false humidity and
temperature are integers and so a random
forest model will be created by
using the four variables comprising of
outlook temperature humidity windy as
the input variable and the play variable
here will be used as the output variable
or the variable that we want to predict
okay and then the the data equals to
weather which is the weather data object
here and we're gonna use number of tree
to be 500 and because there are four
input variables we're just going to use
m try of four okay so let's try building
a model and the model has been built and
let's apply the model for prediction
shall we i mean just to test that the
code is working properly so let's try
applying the model on the input file
that i have previously mentioned about
and so we're going to run this line and
putting the data into the variable
called test okay and then we're going to
assign the factor because if we don't do
it then it'll provide an error so before
we run this line of code let's just try
to make a prediction model and we should
be able to see a error coming up okay so
we got this error error in predict
random forest type of predictor in new
data do not match so what we notice is
that if we type in the str
and then we type in weather and then we
notice that the outlook has factors with
three level but if we type in str and
then the test variable
notice that the outlook has a factor of
only one level and this is because the
input data has only one line of data
which is essentially one row of data and
so the outlook is only sunny so the
prediction being made has only one role
and but in reality it should have three
levels of the factor so we're gonna
define that by telling the code that
there are three possible factors there
are overcast rainy and sunny okay so
let's run that line of code and then run
the prediction again okay and it works
and then print output and here you go we
got the prediction which is exactly what
is going to be displayed on the web
application let me show you
all right we make the prediction and
it's shown here so this table you see
here is shown right here okay so the
model works and let's go to the other
lines of code so the next one would be
the user interface right as i have
mentioned in previous video the user
interface represents the first component
of the shiny web app and this is
followed by the second component which
is the server and then this is followed
by the third component which is the
fusion of the user interface and the
server component using the shiny app
function okay so let's talk about the ui
so this ui object makes use of the fluid
page function and we're gonna use the
theme equals to the shiny theme united
and so the united theme will give the
buttons a red color so if we change it
to cerulean then we're going to have the
cerulean color theme which is a bit blue
okay so please refer to the first video
of the web apps in r in order to see the
selection of web templates that you can
choose from okay so let's run the app
again
and i'm going to put the app just about
right
right here so the header panel is play
golf and so this is right here play golf
so if you want to change the name feel
free to do so and then the next one is
the sidebar panel so the sidebar panel
will accept the input parameters it's
located to the left and there will be a
total of four input and so the first one
is select input which is a drop down
menu and if you click on it you get
three selection sunny overcast rainy and
when you hover on the drop down menu on
sunny it will secretly under the hood
select the sunny object and if you
select on the overcast also it will
under the hood be equivalent to the
overcast object and if you select on the
rainy it will be equivalent to the rainy
object and the default is to select
rainy right here we'll select rainy as
the default what if you change it to
sunny
and let's change the value to be
a high value let's say like 85
and humidity to be 95 and it's windy
that's true
reload the app again right so high
temperature high humidity windy sunny
don't play golf okay so here you can
change the default value to your liking
okay so we have mentioned about the
three data objects for here sunny
overcast and
rainy so keep that in mind we're gonna
make use of that in the server function
and note that when we will refer to it
later on in the server function it will
be referred to as input dollar sign
outlook input dollar sign temperature
input dollar sign humidity and input
dollar sign windy
here why don't we just scroll down and
have a look here input dollar sign
outlook input dollar sign temperature
input dollar sign humidity input dollar
sign windy okay and then let's move back
notice the spelling here using the small
letter not the capital one so the
capital one here are the label so it's
exactly what we're going to see in the
web application outlook with the colon
is right here on the label okay actually
you don't have to type in label if you
don't want to we could just you know
delete it and it will give the same
results
it's just implied okay but if you want
to add the label argument you could feel
free to do so
right but if you do it for one then
we might as well do it for all
so that would actually make the code
looks a bit more easier to read right so
we see here that okay this is the object
name outlook and the label is outlook
with a capital o
reload the app here you go
right it works as usual so here this
outlook here is an outlook object and
this temperature here is the temperature
object and this action button here is
the submit button so this submit button
is added in order to overcome the
reactive function so we'll just add the
familiar submit button so that users can
initiate the prediction process when
they feel ready to do so instead of
having the web app being reactive and
making the prediction spontaneously upon
sliding up and down of the input values
because when it's reactive if you move
it by one notch and then you let go of
the mouse it'll make a prediction but
for this one with the submit button no
prediction will be made until you
actually click on the submit button so
actually this might be a good thing on
the server side because the server will
work a bit less if the prediction being
made is made only once versus if it is
in the reactive mode if you slide the
input value and you just change your
mind later on then prediction will be
made at each point of the changing of
the input value of the slider here or
even the drop down menu right but we do
it once
with the use of the submit button okay
and that's it for this left sidebar
panel
and then the main panel here will
display the result from the output
generated by the server function so
we're going to talk about that in just a
moment so why don't we note that the
output being generated by the server
component will be called contents and
table data okay okay so let's hop on to
the server function which is the second
component so in this data set input
variable it will comprise of the first
component is it will create a data frame
which will accept four input values from
the web application comprising of the
outlook temperature humidity windy
which is right here outlook temperature
humidity windy and then it will combine
it with the play variable which is the
fifth column of the original data set
and then it will transpose the data set
it will rotate it it will transpose it
and then write a input.csv file it will
read the input.csv file back in into the
test variable and then it will apply the
factor function in order to tell that
the outlook has three levels and finally
a prediction will be made using the
model generated earlier by means of the
random forest and apply the prediction
model to predict the input values from
the user and once the prediction is made
it will be sent from here into the
output dollar sign table data as the
function data set input right here and
then it's going to render the table as
we will see in the web application
so the table that is being rendered will
be right here which comprises of three
columns the prediction the no and the
yes probability okay and this status
output text box is just essentially this
box right here so if we load the app for
the first time it will just say server
is ready for calculation and if we click
on the submit button the text will
change to calculation complete and then
it will be followed by the prediction
results table okay so note that there
are two outputs being generated right
here output dollar sign contents output
dollar sign table data so these two
output will be sent to the ui component
right here table data and contents right
table data will be displayed as a table
using the table output function and the
status of the prediction whether it is
ready for prediction or prediction has
been made would be displayed by the
verbatim text output function okay and
this is just the label of the status
output text box shown right here that
we're going to have the h3 font size
okay i mean if you want to change it to
h2 make it a bit bigger then you will
notice that the font will become bigger
right so i'm just going to make it back
to h3
okay
so that's all right and then the the
last component shiny app function will
just fuse the ui and the server together
okay and you have all of this in
121 lines of code and so nothing fancy
here just a simple web application that
you can create using the shiny language
okay so this video represents the fourth
episode of the web apps in r series and
today we're going to cover about how we
can develop a iris predictor which is a
machine learning model in the background
and the web app allows the user to
select the input values for the four
input parameters and press on the submit
button and make a prediction so without
further ado let's get started
okay so the first thing that you want to
do is go to the data professor github
okay once you arrive here you click on
the code link and then find shiny and
then click on the 004 iris predictor so
what you want to do now is to download
the first three files comprising of the
app numeric.r
appslider.r and the model.r because the
other three files found below will be
generated automatically when we run the
code okay so why don't we just click on
each of them manually and then for each
right click on the raw button and click
on the save link as okay and then you
select the location in your computer
where you want to save the files so you
do this for all three files the app
numeric.r appslider.r and the model.r
okay so i have already done that and i
will go back to the rstudio application
okay so before we begin let's have a
look at what does the iris predictor web
application that we are going to develop
today looks like so you want to hit on
the run app you need to make sure that
your working directory is at the folder
where it contains all of the necessary
files to be run the one that you have
just downloaded okay and once you have
made sure already you want to click on
the run app button all right so this is
what the app looks like and it allows
you to put in the four input parameters
and so these are the default values
which you can adjust accordingly and
then when you click on the submit button
the prediction will be made and here the
prediction is made to be that the input
parameter is predicted to be a iris
sutosa flower and the probability of it
being a irish dosa is a hundred percent
okay and so if you change the input
parameters
and so the prediction will also be
changed because the input parameter will
be feed into the predictive model which
is a random forest and then the random
forest will perform the classification
and it has classified this input
parameter as a rs virginica with 100
probability so let's have a look under
the hood what does the code actually
looks like okay so the first code that
you want to open up right now is the
model.r so in this tutorial we're going
to pre-build the random forest model and
then we're going to load it in right so
as you recall in the previous videos of
this channel we have shown you how you
can deploy your predictive model into a
rds file and so what you want to do is
you develop the model in this model.r
file and you save it as the rds right so
you're deploying that and then you're
going to read that in here on line
number 15 you're going to read the model
dot rds in and you're going to give it a
name the name is model and then we're
going to use this model for making the
prediction so the advantage of this is
that the model is already built and so
there is no additional workload on the
shiny application so it can just readily
read in the model and perform the
classification so this will be
beneficial in the case in which the
predictive model will take a long time
to build the model okay so let's have a
look at the model.r file where we will
be building the model so the first steps
that we want to do now is to load in the
libraries which will include the r curl
and the random forest so the r curl
library will allow us to read the data
professor github to download the iris
data set and then the random forest will
be used to create the prediction model
and we also need the carrot package in
order to do the data splitting okay so
iris here will mean that we will create
a data object called iris because we're
going to read in the csv which will
retrieve the csv file from the data
professor github and the file is called
iris.csv okay and then it will use the
carrot package to perform data splitting
using a ratio of 80 20. so 0.8 here is
the 80 split which will go into the
training index and then we will
subsequently use the training index to
create a training set in which it will
perform slicing of the original iris
data frame and then the remainder 20
will go to the testing set so what we're
going to do next is we're going to write
the training set and the testing set out
into the csv files right because that
would help to remedy possible shuffling
of the data that will go into the
training set and the testing set so it
will allow reproducibility in the future
so in the future we can just read in the
training.csv file instead of performing
the data splitting again right so here
we're going to read in the training.csv
file and give it the same name which is
the train set okay and then we're gonna
delete the first column which is the
index number and then we're going to
build a model and assign the built model
into the model data object and once a
model has been built we're going to save
it as the rds file so that we're going
to deploy the model into the rds format
so in this random force function code
we're specifying that we want to predict
the species of the iris flower and we're
going to use all four input parameters
and the data set will be using the
training set for making the model and
then we're going to assign a entry value
which is the parameter of the random
forest to be 500 and we're going to
assign the m tri parameter to be four
right and then we're gonna assign a true
value for the importance argument okay
and so so what you want to do is you
want to run all of this
blocks of code so you can just control a
select everything and then ctrl enter
okay and then the data will be read and
then a model will be built and it will
be saved as the model dot rds
okay so this concludes the model dot r
file and then we're gonna close that and
then we're gonna open up the second file
which is the app numeric dot r okay so
let's have a look the first few lines
will be importing the necessary
libraries which will be the shiny
library the data dot table the random
forest package and then we're going to
read in the model that we have built in
the previous step and we're going to
assign it into a model object right and
then like in previous video the shiny
web application will contain three
components so the first component being
the ui and the second component being
the server and the third component being
the shiny app function which will
essentially piece together the ui and
the server okay so let's have a look at
the ui and we're going to open up the
web application and have a look right at
the same time and for readability of the
code i would just add additional enters
to it a new line to it so that when i
open up the web browser concurrently the
values here won't be hidden
okay
save it and go back to the web
application all right so here the name
of this web application is called iris
predictor and so it is in the header
panel here so we put in the iris
predictor if you want to change the name
feel free to do so right here and then
we're going to have the sidebar panel
which is on the left and then we're
going to have the main bar panel which
is on the right so as always the left or
the sidebar panel will take in the input
parameters and then clicking on the
submit button which is right here it
will send the input parameters to the
server function and the server will use
that input parameters to feed it in to
the predictive model which is the random
forest model and make a prediction and
once the prediction has been made the
resulting output value generated will
then be feedback into the main panel
right here and then the results will be
displayed in the table data which is
going to be occurring right below this
text message so the table data will be
shown right here which is the prediction
being made okay so in the input
parameters we're going to use the html
tag and then inside we're going to
assign a size of the header to be h3
right and the name will be input
parameters right here so further showing
the versatility of the shiny application
framework so notice that the s and l are
capital letter and this is the id of
this input parameter simple length and
it is case sensitive so we have to type
it in exactly as is when we're going to
use it in the next step so it's going to
be like input dollar sign and then
simple.linked and then this will be the
input parameter which the server
function will be using as the data to be
fed into the random forest model okay
and so the label here will be simple
lane and the label means right here the
label and the value is the default value
which is five and here is five so if you
change the default value to 5.1 and you
save it run the app again and so you see
that the 5.1 will be updated right here
in place of the 5.0 okay and so the same
thing will be for the simple width pedal
length width right with the label and
with the value which is the default
values right here and then the next
block of code here is the action button
function and this will be the submit
button so it will overwrite the reactive
function in which when there is no
submit button every time we modify the
numbers in here a prediction will be
made so that would put a heavy load onto
the server because every time that you
update the value here a prediction will
be made so imagine that you update the
values 10 times 20 times and 20
predictive models will be created
whereas in a situation where you have
the submit button you can spend all the
time or as many times as you need to
update the values right let's say 5.2
and then i change my mind i want to have
it 4.9 so do this 10 more times and so
the prediction model will not be built
right so it's going to wait for you
until you click on the submit button and
then the prediction will be made okay so
this will be more economical on the
server side and also for familiarity
where we normally would click on some
button in order to initiate the process
of the prediction okay and then the
following block of code main panel will
be right here so in the tags label h3
status output it will be this part so
notice that this block of code is
exactly the same as the html block of
code so i'm just showing you the
versatility of the shiny web application
and
you could use either one okay but this
is the shiny way of doing things right
so let me show you by putting it right
here and then i'm going to comment that
out and put in the input parameters here
and then replace the value inside
okay reload the application right and
then it looks exactly the same right so
you can do it both ways all right and
then the following text box shown here
will tell you that the server is ready
for calculation so this will be
displayed upon loading of the web
application and upon clicking on the
submit button the value will be changed
to be calculation complete okay so this
will be on the server side so i will
show you in just a moment okay so we
finished with the ui component and now
let's go on to the server component and
so here we're going to load in the
function okay so this block of code here
will be the input parameters which will
be obtained from the ui component where
the user will input the input parameters
and click on the submit button and upon
doing that all of the input parameters
will come in as shown in this block of
code here and this block of code will
essentially generate the input csv file
which will be read into the test object
and then apply the model to make a
prediction on this test object and once
the prediction has been made this block
of code data set input will contain the
prediction and the prediction value will
be inserted right here right and then
it's going to be encapsulated by a
output table data variable name and then
this thing and then the input dollar
sign and then the output dollar sign
table data will be sent to the main
panel in the ui to be displayed so it's
right here right so this one will come
from the table data right here table
data right this highlighted in blue and
it will be coming from the prediction
results table right which we use the
render table function here and the data
set input here will contain the
prediction which is coming out from the
output data object okay so let me go
specifically line by line here so a data
frame will be created and then name will
be the name of the header variable name
on the first row and then the values
will take in the input parameter value
from the ui so input dollar sign simple
length simple width pedal length pedal
width will come from the input text box
right here 5.1 3.6 1.4 0.2 so this text
box will be the input dollar sign simple
link simple with pedal link put away
okay and then we're going to create a
data frame and once we have done that we
will write it out as a input.csv file
and we're going to read it back in and
then we're going to put it into the test
object and then we're going to create a
output object and a data frame will be
created and we apply the prediction
function in order to make a prediction
using the random force model on the
input test data and once the prediction
has been made we will also tell the
probability in three digits okay and
once a prediction has been made it would
then be sent to this output data object
and it will print it out and it will be
representing the data set input and this
dataset input will be inserted into the
rendertable function and a table will be
generated to show you the output
prediction results shown right here
right okay so that's essentially it for
this iris predictor in the numeric form
so let's close this and hop on to the
next one
okay so now we're going to proceed with
the app slider version and before doing
so you want to clean the workspace
environment so click on the broom button
and then after you have done that then
you want to click on the app slider dot
r and then ctrl a and then ctrl enter
right and then the web app will be
loaded so you see that now instead of a
text box where we put in the numerical
value you're going to have a slider
right and then you click on the input
parameter by sliding
here and then after you're satisfied
with the input values then you will
click on the submit button and then the
prediction will be made and as always it
looks exactly the same but the only
difference is the input parameters will
have the slider bar instead of the text
box okay so let's have a look under the
hood so what new code did we add to this
file so we've added lines 17 18 and 19
and then we've also added two new
arguments which is the minimum and the
maximum argument into each of the inputs
and we also change the name from numeric
input into slider input and that's
essentially it we just change a couple
of lines of code and the web app will
look like this instead of a numeric text
box we're going to have a slider bar so
the value of the minimum here will be
taken as the minimum function and then
the train set dollar sign simple length
right so i don't have to manually put in
the minimum value or maximum value but i
will do this programmatically so i'm
going to use the minimum function and
inside the minimum function as the
argument i'm going to say okay i want to
have the train set object and i want to
have the simple link column and i want
to know what is the minimum value right
it's going to be like this so let me
close this and i'm going to read in the
file so let me show you how it looks
like and if i run the
train set
it will look like this and then i'm
going to run this line and then notice
that
the first column will be gone right i
don't want the index to be shown so i
just delete it out and then when i say
train set dollar sign simple length what
i get would be this so it's going to be
the values of only the first column and
upon adding the minimum function
in front
i'm going to get the minimum value
and if i use the maximum function i'm
going to get the maximum value of this
column so the minimum is 4.3 and the
maximum is 7.9 so instead of putting in
the values manually 4.3 7.9 i'm going to
do it programmatically and it's going to
be so much easier right and then i just
put it in right here and that's all for
modifying the code and everything else
works exactly the same and you get a new
feel to the web application and it's not
that difficult okay so play around and
let me know what kind of web application
you want to be made and or the input
data that you want me to use for making
the web app
okay so today represents the fifth
episode of the web apps in r series and
today we're going to cover about how you
can develop a
bmi calculator so if you're wondering
what is a bmi
so essentially bmi stands for body mass
index
and it is computed by dividing the
weights in kilograms by the height in
squared meters so for example if you
weight 70 kilograms and you are 170
centimeters tall then you would first
have to convert the height to a meter so
170 centimeters would then become 1.7
meters and according to the equation you
would take your weight which is 70
kilograms divided by 1.7 meter squared
okay so let me calculate that so 1.7
times 1.7
would be 2.89
and
if i weighed
70 kilograms
divide that by
the squared height
then my bmi would be 24.2
okay so let's have a look at the scale
of the bmi in adults so if you have a
bmi below 18.5 then it would mean that
you are under weight
if you have a bmi in the range of 18.5
and 24.9
then it means that you have a healthy
weight
and if your bmi is between 25 to
29.9 it means that you are overweight
and if you have bmi of greater than 30
then you are obese okay so in the
previous example a bmi of 24.2 would
mean that the weight is
a healthy weight
so without further ado let's get started
in developing our bmi web application so
you want to go first to the github of
the data professor
and so click on the code folder
find shiny and click on the shiny folder
and then find the zero 005 dash bmi
click on that
and then you want to download both the
about
md and the app.r into your computer so
why don't we do that right right click
on the raw
save link as
and because we're going to download it
into a bmi folder
we save it there
and then download the second file
right click on the raw link
save link as
save it to the folder bmi
okay and now we have
to upload the
folder
okay there you have it you have two
files app.r and about.md so let's have a
quick look at what does the file look
like so as you show the app.r is the r
code comprising of the three major
components the ui the user interface
number two is the server and number
three is the shiny app function which
fuses both the ui and the server
function and then the second file you
have the about dot md
so this is written in the markdown
language and it's going to be used by
the app.r file so we're going to see
that in just a
moment so before we dive deep into the r
code let's have a look what does the web
application looks like click on the run
app
okay so this is a simple web application
where you can put in your input height
and your weight
so the height will be in centimeters and
the weight will be in kilograms
so the minimum value here is 40 for the
height and 250 for the maximum value and
for the weight the minimum value is 20
and the maximum value is 100 so please
note that this bmi calculator is
developed for adults and it's not
suitable for children if you want to
develop a bmi for children then you will
have to refer to this second link here
okay so as you notice that when i click
on the about link on the navigation bar
it shows the information in the about
page so originally the code was written
here in markdown language and here in
the website it displays it as a normal
web page so here you can add boldness to
the text you can add superscript make it
stand out as an equation you could add
italic font right so all of this is
within the markdown language right for
example if you for example if you use
two asterisk it will mean that the tests
will be in both text so meaning that you
have to use two asterisks before and
after the text you want to meet both and
if you use the for hashtag it means that
you're going to use the header level 4
tag which is the h4 tag in html and if
you're using the greater than symbol
here it means that it's going to display
this light gray bar to the left so you
know that it's an equation and if you
use one asterisk then it means that the
text will be in italic form right and
here we use the for hashtag again and so
it becomes a header and then we make the
bmi calculator in italic form by using
the asterisk before and after and even
add the links to the website right so
the text that you want to make into a
link you have to put that in bracket and
immediately following that you have to
put in parenthesis the url of the
webpage and so this is formatted like a
normal web page and so the web
application and so the web application
is mobile friendly and you can
use it on your mobile phone okay it
would look something like this on the
phone and if you click on it then you
get the bmi right in my previous example
a height of 170 and a weight of 70 you
would get a bmi of 24.22145
and because we're rounding it and
therefore we get 24.22 okay so this web
application seems simple enough okay and
so let's dive deep into the r code okay
so let's have a look at the code of the
app.r file so the first two lines here
will be the loading in of the library
package of shiny and shiny themes and
then following that we have the user
interface so inside the ui object it's
going to be the fluid page function and
here we will define that we're going to
use the shiny theme of united and let's
run the app and have a look okay so here
the navbar page function shows that
we're going to use the name of this
navigation bar to be bmi calculator and
then the tab panel will have the first
navigation tab here to be home okay and
inside
tab panel here we're going to use the
sidebar panel and the main panel so as
usual the sidebar panel is right here to
the left and to the right in the status
output we're going to have the main
panel right so the sidebar panel will
contain the input parameters which
comprises of two input parameters the
height and the weight and we're using a
slider input so you can slide
the bar here
and then you get the desired value click
on the submit button
and then you get the calculated bmi
value okay so the slider input here is
responsible for this slider button and
so the name of this slider input is
called height here in label height and
the first one will be the id of this
specific slider input and so this slider
input has an id of height notice the
small h and then the second slider input
has a value of weight and notice the
small w and so these two slider input
will then be used in the next step it
will be used by the server function as
the input dollar sign weight and input
dollar sign heights in order to
calculate the bmi okay and then the
action button function will be the red
button that you click to initiate the
calculation process and so the main
panel will have the h3 tag here showing
the status output okay and then the
verbatim text output will contain the
contents id which is from the output in
the server function and in the table
output is also from the output of the
server function it is called the table
data and this is the table data
containing the computed bmi value so let
me recap that again
so here the slider input we have two of
them height and weight and so it will be
referred to as input dollar sign height
input dollar sign weight and as the user
slides this value it will adjust the
value to the height parameter or the
weight parameter and the input dollar
sign height value and the input dollar
sign weight value would then go to the
server function
i will show you right now
right here so we go to the server
function in the equation that we're
going to compute the bmi so here we're
taking the input dollar sign weight
dividing it by and in parenthesis the
input dollar sign height divided by 100
right because we want to convert the
centimeters to become meter so we have
to divide the centimeter value by 100
and that will then make it a meter form
and then we're going to multiply the
height by itself so that we get the
squared height value
and then we're going to divide the
weight by the height in order to get the
bmi and we're going to encapsulate the
bmi value inside a data frame so that we
can display it in the final output here
below in the output contents it will
show that the server is ready for
calculation or the server has already
completed the calculation so this will
be modified by the submit button the red
button that we clicked right here so
when we don't click the button it will
say server is ready for calculation but
upon clicking on the red button the bmi
will be calculated and then in this text
box the text will change to calculation
complete okay and in the following
output results here it's called the
output dollar sign table data and inside
here we're going to use the render table
function so the results from the data
set input will be the computed bmi value
right here in the print bmi so let me
recap again let's have a look at the web
application again so this web
application will take two input
parameters the height and the weight and
they are in the centimeter unit and the
height and the weight will be referred
to as input dollar sign height and input
dollar sign weight and upon clicking on
the red button it will be sent to the
server function into this bmi calculator
function so it will then take the input
weight and the input height and perform
the calculation and return the bmi value
and then we put the bmi value into a
data frame and then we print it out and
the results of the bmi that is printing
out is part of the dataset input
variable and that is called within the
render table function
of the output dollar sign table data and
the output dollar sign table data will
go to the main panel right here in the
main panel
to be displayed in the table output and
it looks like this right here so you see
that it's called bmi and then we have
the bmi value right beneath it right and
that's all there is to building this bmi
web application so you can play around
with this code and you can change the
default value for example the height you
can make it 180 and the value of the
weight you could make it say 75 right
and then run the code again and so the
default value then becomes updated to be
180 and 75 so let's say that you want to
update the maximum value to be 300
minimum value to be
50 and the weight you want to update it
to say 30 and
the maximum would be
and then reload the application and here
you see the minimum values and maximum
values are updated accordingly so you
see here if the weight is maintained the
same and
the height increases then the bmi
becomes less but if the height decreases
then the bmi is high right because of
the equation of the bmi
whereby the weight is divided by the
height squared okay and so you can play
around adjusting the values
play around with the template
so let's say you want to change the
united theme to become a cerulean
save it reload the app and here you go
you get a different colored web
application right so the types of theme
could be obtained
by
looking at the websites
you could google that
google for shiny themes click on the
click on the rstudio.github.io
slash shiny themes so i'll provide the
link in the description down below so
check that out
in this video i'm going to show you how
you could deploy a r shiny web
application and without further ado
we're starting right now okay so the
first thing that you want to do is head
over to the github of the data professor
and you want to click on repositories
then find and click on the iris r heroku
and so all of the files that are needed
to deploy your app is found here so feel
free to clone this to your own github or
also you could download the entire
folder content here by clicking on the
code and then download zip file so let's
have a look here so you're going to see
that we have the ui.r which is the user
interface and we also have server.r
which is the server side component of
the web app so essentially the our shiny
web app will be comprised of two
components the user interface and the
server component and then we're gonna
have the training data set and the
testing data set as the csv file and the
actual model will be contained within
the
dot rds and so the machine learning
model is saved as the model dot rds and
it will be loaded into the web
application when we run it and then
there are two additional r files let's
have a look so the first one is init dot
r
and so let's have a look here so it will
allow us to install the necessary
libraries so we're gonna install the
random forest and the data dot table
and the run.r
will allow us to run the r shiny and
assign the proper ports okay and so
that's all there is to having the
necessary components for deploying your
r shiny web application so let's head
over to heroku and so you want to click
on new
create new app
and then you want to give the app a name
so let me call it dp
iris
r
create app
and then i want to connect to github
and
i'll find iris or hiroku
so for your case you want to find your
own github and you wanna find your own
iris r hiroku
and then connect
and then this is very important because
you wanna click on settings
and in order to have the support for r
you're going to need to add the custom
build pack and so you want to click on
the add build pack
and you're going to notice that there
are some officially supported build tags
so by default you're going to have
python right and then you're going to
have others like php ruby java node.js
and so for r we're going to use a third
party
and the third party link to the build
pack for r is given here so i'm going to
provide you this link in the description
of this video so you want to copy that
and then put it here as well and then
click on save changes
and then you're going to see that it has
been added successfully here
now you want to head back to deploy
scroll down and you want to click on
deploy branch in the manual deploy
so at this point you want to take a
break grab a cup of coffee and wait for
the web app to deploy
and so we're going to see the log of
what is happening here
so initially it is installing version
3.6.3
here and it is downloading the build
pack directly from amazon web service
and also having shiny as well
all right so it's installing the
data.table library
and right now it's building the
environment
and so this web application has already
been built in a previous video so the
links to that video will be provided in
the description down below and in the
meantime maybe i could show you that
shiny
and it is number four iris predictor
and so you're gonna notice that
we've been using the testing and
training and for the app we divided the
components of ui and server into the
separate files
okay and so it's compressing the
environment from
megabytes to
121 megabytes
oh no the r packages occupies 121
megabytes
okay so it has compressed it down to 152
and it is deploying the web application
to dp dash iris-r dot hiroku app.com so
in just a moment you're going to see a
link to view the deployed website
okay it's finished and so it says that
your app was successfully deployed let's
click on it
all right so it says here that server is
ready for calculation
let's submit it
all right so prediction seems to work
and it is predicted to be setosa with a
probability of a hundred percent
okay this predicts it to be setosa as
well
same thing
setosa
and now it is predicted to be virginica
100 virginica
thank you for watching until the end of
this video and i hope that this video
was helpful to you and for more
tutorials in data science bioinformatics
as well as python and r coding tutorials
please check out my youtube channel at
the data professor and also my new and
second youtube channel the coding
professor and you could also find me on
the medium platform where i blog about
data science as well as doing python
tutorials and last but not least i would
like to thank free code cam for this
awesome collaboration and please don't
forget to smash the like button
subscribe if you haven't already and
until next time the best way to learn
data science is to do data science
please enjoy the journey